foreign
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with the director of the John Smith
Center Kezia dugdale and Barrister and
former government Minister Anna subri so
let's see what's on some of those front
pages for you now escape from cartoon is
the headline on the front of the Metro
as the newspaper reports on diplomatic
evacuations from Sudan
that story also features on the
telegraph which says UK citizens feel
abandoned by the foreign office
and the express also leads on the
evacuation from Sudan detailing the
dramatic rescue effort by SAS forces
the eye says Diane Abbott's fighting for
her political career after having the
labor whip suspended over her comments
published in The Observer
the times also leads on that story with
the headline Corbin Ally Sparks new
labor row over racism
The Daily Mirror reports that sir Rod
Stewart is stepping up his calls for
nurses to get a fair pay rise
time to scrap the tourist tax and get
Britain booming again is the headline on
the front of the Daily Mail
while the Daily Star turns its attention
to several upcoming heat waves in the UK
which are expected to start over the
king's coronation
and remind you that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
watch us
and we are joined tonight by Kezia
dugdale and Anna subri welcome to you
both let's start with the metro and the
Very worrying story unfolding from Sudan
the fierce fighting that many British
Nationals and others have been caught up
in and their headline escape from
Khartoum Anna take us into this story
so we know that there is this very
serious situation developing in Sudan
and the government quite rightly and
understandably wants to get people
British Nationals and of course all the
Diplomatic teams out of there as soon as
possible the criticism is that the
government's slow excuse me and it's not
in particular dealing with the British
Nationals to be fair I think what the
foreign secretary was trying to say
James cleverley I don't think he said it
very well was that the priority had to
be Embassy staff to get them into a safe
place so that they can continue their
work then to get those British Nationals
out
on the front page of the metro and
others is referring to some remarkable
operation led by the SAS but of course
everybody's real fear is that we don't
have a repetition of the outrage in
Afghanistan when I'm afraid we
absolutely failed to do the right thing
by people and getting them out of there
we've heard from some British Nationals
um in cartoon in Sudan Kezia and they're
saying that they feel
um abandoned
yes right now it feels like they have
every reason to feel that way watching a
flight leave with all the Diplomatic
support from the country that they are
still living in and is right to point to
the reminiscence that brings of what
happened in Afghanistan with people
queuing at the gates of the airport
waiting for aircraft to arrive we don't
know just exactly how many British
Nationals there are in Sudan at the
minute and the government are asking
people in the country to register a form
on the internet to make themselves known
it seems quite a bit behind the efforts
that other countries are making at this
stage a number of the papers point to
situation in Ireland where they seem to
have a very specific number of citizens
in the country are communicating with
them already and making plans to get
them out so a strong sense here that the
UK government and the foreign secretary
in particular are behind the curve when
really rapid actions required because
the situation is escalating very very
quickly
let's move on to the times Anna and this
story that's um emerged today involving
Diane Abbott who has um lost the labor
whip over comments that she's made um
suggesting that Jewish people can't
suffer racism
this is extraordinary she wrote a letter
that was in The Observer Today where she
said that actually she said it about uh
the Roma people as well and I think I
think the Irish and she she said that
the racism which undoubtedly these
people have suffered for centuries
appalling racism
she likened it to the prejudices that
people with ginger had suffered and
sought to to draw a distinction between
again the importing racism suffered by
black people and it's it's just it's
just such a load of nonsense but it's
deeply offensive but then she put out a
statement it's completely retracting and
apologizing and saying well this was
just a draft and actually I think all of
this it it actually poses more questions
the fact that what she says in her
attraction because she happily writes
something and then so I didn't really
mean to write all of that it was just a
draft well how did it get sent and
actually I believe in the exact opposite
to what I wrote and sent to a newspaper
anyway labor has suspended the whip
they've acted very quickly quite rightly
so but it's going to be the Fallout
because if she doesn't get the wit back
she can't stand as a labor Member of
Parliament so
quite rightly this is making a lot of
news and it's going to be interesting to
see how things develop in the next week
Kezia what are your thoughts
so Anna's right to say that Dan Abbott's
remarks are offensive they're also
deeply regrettable and utterly avoidable
this is a proactive letter she wrote To
The Observer it didn't need to happen it
wasn't like she was involving herself in
a spot or speaking from a panel a
particularly heated exchange know that
that would justify the comments but this
was completely regrettable unavoidable
and it's really quite shocking and it's
left cure starmer with with no option
other than to suspend her from the party
not least because he's put so much truck
recently into trying to rebuild
relationships with the Jewish community
and has made a lot of Headway in that
regard you have leading Jewish
politicians like Luciana Berger a former
colleague of Anna's rejoining the labor
party because they believed that enough
effort had been made enough progress had
been made to regain the support of the
Jewish Community but all of that would
be up in the air again if labor hadn't
acted as decisively as they had tonight
it's a very sad story though because
Diana is a formidable politician she's
the first black female politician to be
elected in the United Kingdom she's I
know many occasions have been on the
wrong side of debates but they were in
the labor party but she's somebody that
broadly the labor party is extremely
proud of and she's now in a situation
where the labor party in the middle of
selecting candidates for the next
general election she might find herself
without the Whip and unable to stand in
her happy constituency bringing her
entire political career to an end
because of an offensive clumsy and
utterly avoidable letter to the Press
and Anna would you describe it as
anti-Semitism we went to Stamford Hill
and spoke to some of her constituents
and um a Jewish gentleman said that
dynab had done a lot for the the Jewish
community and she she perhaps just
misspoke
no I don't think she misspoke at all she
wrote this and she sent it and and I'm
afraid it it absolutely chimes with what
a lot of Jewish people in particular
have found under the reign of corbyn and
just generally amongst if you like the
hard left is this trying to make ad that
you know this a terrible anti-Semitism
uh and
and and what she said was just I mean
it's wrong it's just factually wrong but
it is profoundly offensive to Jewish
people six million were murdered in the
gas Chambers for goodness sakes and that
was because of racism I mean to liken it
to a Prejudice and for people with
ginger hair it's just extraordinary
um but it
it and from Diana of all people because
of the appalling racism that she has
suffered throughout the whole of her
time in politics but I think it it is
part of this feature Casio knows more
about this than I do this feature of the
hard left in the labor party and their
links with anti-Semitism and you will
remember that that was a huge part of
what finally led to the end of Jeremy
corbyn and indeed his expulsion from the
Parliamentary party
um and this determination by starmer to
stamp out this anti-Semitism in the
labor party yeah so Jeremy corbyn um
always denied claims of him being
anti-semitic but Kezia just to to finish
off on this subject I wonder if you
think this is the end of Diane Abbott's
political career
I'm afraid I do and you wish it wasn't
because in many ways I've got a huge
amount of admiration for her the thing
that people forget about down Abbott and
Anna's pointed or referenced it a little
bit there is she's an extraordinary
woman when it comes to to firsts and
also she tracks uh an incredible amount
of abuse online there's a recent report
showed that half of the entire abuse is
based on politicians online is directed
at Diane Abbott and yet she's managed to
kind of force her way through that get
herself on the front foot get up every
day and do her job serving her
constituents and all of that is thrown
away I think by this letter and which is
so deeply offensive but also there is no
choice for secured armor other than to
suspend her the timing is awful I I it's
very difficult to see if there's any
route back for her now
Anna let's talk about the phone alert I
was going to say which we all got today
but we all didn't get it today and the
the headline for the telegraph phone
alert test ends in fast did you get the
alert
no I didn't get it I feel completely
left out and no I'm not on the three
Network I think it's because I
have a mobile phone signal where I like
where I live like actually far too many
across the whole of the United Kingdom I
mean it is pitiful and outrageous that
there are places where there is no
mobile phone system but I think I just
assumed I'd get it because I use the
Wi-Fi thing that means that you can use
a mobile phone system don't ask me to
explain it anyway I didn't get it but a
lot of other people didn't get it either
and I don't know what they're gonna do
they're going to do it all over again
because there clearly is a problem
um with it looks like this one
particular Network
so are you worried that you didn't get
it
that if it was uh for real you'd be left
out in the cold
well I mean I actually think it's a
really good idea this and I think for
flooding in particular you know I mean I
don't live in an area where we
particularly suffer from floods but
that's really not the point is it
because lots of people who didn't get
this will live in areas like that so I
didn't have a problem with the principle
of it all but if you're going to do it
it's got to work
because yeah we read that it uh failed
to work on up to 10 million phones
hardly a success
well that's obviously a huge number
given the number of people that live in
the United Kingdom I I did get it and I
got an Almighty Frank I must admit even
though knowing the test was child was
expected today and they came back on
three o'clock in my house it set the dog
off everybody was going down for about
10 minutes and then 10 minutes later
actually my wife received the text
message late because that's the other
part of the story lots of people didn't
get it bang on cue and the whole thing
happened again it's quite an important
resource I think for the government to
be able to to do this you know it does
um give you some degree of confidence
that something awful happened there's a
way to communicate with people but 10
million of them not getting the messages
without doubt something to be concerned
about
yes the government has insisted though
that it was a success but senior MP
suggests the scheme was a waste of
taxpayers money that should be scrapped
and Jacob Bruce Morgan's quoted here
former cabinet minister said it was an
expansion of the reach of the state that
was redundant
thank you both we shall speak to you in
a moment just uh I hope you can see
Anna's expression there we're going to
take a break Anna hold that thought
we'll be back coming up but should
nurses wear body cameras the telegraph
reports the government is considering
the measure in a bid to reduce sexual
assaults
[Music]
foreign
welcome back you are watching The Press
preview still with me once again the
director of the John Smith Center Kezia
dugdale and Barrister and former
government Minister Anna subri so let us
take you through this section of the
paper so we're going to have a look at
the telegraph to start with uh and this
story quite interesting story that
nurses are to be given body warm cameras
in an effort to curb Hospital sexual
assaults Kezia
absolutely astonishing goodies since
2019 there have been 6 500 perceptual
results within across the protecting
which is I think is when you think about
it but it's also obviously leading
Representatives as nurses and possible
staff to be asking for greater measures
to protect them security while they're
at their place of work and that's led to
these calls for nurses to wear body cams
much like paramedics or indeed police
officers or other fresh responders do in
unknown difficult dangerous situations
it's just quite astonishing really to
think that something like that might be
so necessary within hospitals where
nurses are caring for a very sick people
who you would expect to be grateful for
the help and support they're getting
from nurses rather than actually be a
threat to the people that are trying to
provide them with support yes I mean
they shouldn't have to to wear them but
Anna do you think that they are
necessary and it's actually a good idea
now
safe but
as Casio says this outrageous figure and
I think it actually is this figure is
not just inside hospitals it's hot
foreign
members of staff are walking to their
cars or going to catch the bus or
whatever it may be about a long and late
shift of upside who shouldn't be there
and it's it you feel as if it's a bit
like you shouldn't have to do this to be
safe we we just we shouldn't have a
society for goodness sake we're six and
a half thousand reports of rape and
sexual assaults since 2019 that is a
shocking statistic
yes it is absolutely but if it keeps on
safe but but it shouldn't be like this
yeah something feels wrong about about
this yeah that is the point that they
shouldn't need
um to wear body cams uh but staying with
with nurses and the mirrors covering a
story which I think we um we broke some
weeks ago this is the Rod Stewart saying
that nurses should get a rise now
Kezia
yes and it's astonishing to come from
Sir Rod Stewart who for many years was a
significant supporter of the
conservative party it's not the first
time he's spoken out against the
government of the day but he's doing so
with particular Force This Time by
standing up for nurses who are obviously
still striking in England and Wales over
their pain demanding a pay rise which
meets the extent the cost of the living
crisis that they're all currently
experiencing and it's nice to see
celebrity figures like sir Royster
making the case because it puts the
issue back on the front pages again
after they've died off because of bigger
stories for example like what's
happening in Sudan or or whatever else
so it's a nice boost I think to the
morale of nurses who are just trying to
get a decent pay for the incredibly
important job that they do of course
Roger made that pledge and carried
through of funding uh some MRI scans
when he'd uh phoned into our NHS phone
in I mean is it that the place of
celebrities do you think Anna to make
comment like this
absolutely why not he's entitled to his
views and I'm sure you'd be delighted if
you could phone in again and perhaps
share his views on doctors and pay Rises
but yeah good on him he's a National
Treasure uh and of course as Kezia says
he's a former conservative who isn't
particularly impressed with the
conservative government
um and I'm sure he speaks for many
millions of other people in that respect
because you finally the London Marathon
went off without a hitch Extinction
Rebellion activist gathered on the
streets nearby but didn't disrupt
yes and 49 000 people completed the
London Marathon today a really cracking
number there I think if I was doing it I
still might be out on the streets of
London so I'm full of awe for everybody
who's completed it no matter what time
they came in or no matter what
outrageous costume they were really
whilst they were doing it it's a
phenomenal event in the calendar and I'm
so pleased it's managed to avoid the
disruption and protest we've seen that
so many other big sporting occasions in
the past few days yes and Anna it was uh
Simo pharah's last uh professional
Marathon
forgive me but Jillian is that right
because the guy saw somewhere that he
was going to do is it is it the
Manchester one anyway because it's
London the last London I I
oh last London yeah the last London one
he's he's just outstanding what a role
model he is for people but I I love all
these marathons I just think they're
fabulous in fact all those distances and
as casual says people do them and all
for all sorts of reasons and so many
people do it to raise money and they
dress up in ponkers costumes God knows
how they run all those miles dressed
like that
um and it's extraordinary and it's
brilliant I think you've got one in
Edinburgh uh in May haven't you've got
the uh I don't think is running in it
though
thank you both for taking us through the
papers we'll see in the next hour thank
you